[Music]
we've been doing something lately I've
been I've been playing and reviewing
popular video games as a service for our
viewers from my latest review we had our
fans pick the game we asked them what do
you want me to review well most of the
fans unanimously said you've got to
tackle the super popular video game
minecraft all right yes I had not
experienced minecraft before I sat down
got a little help and here's my review
we asked you guys what game do you want
me to rate and you said minecraft my
friend Erin Blair and I are going to
play minecraft I don't play video games
I'm not kidding I don't know anything
about this I know nothing about it I
thought this was one of those neck
massager from Brookstone this game is
all about mining things and then
building things taking things out of the
ground and building things corrected
right so so it's like we're in Wales in
the 19th century and we're desperately
poor what a fun game for kids every game
starts in a randomly generated world all
right so so you can walk around we're
like in a forest yeah I'm going through
some grass and that hole with rebel
avoid is a pig thing you see me yeah yes
you yeah hey why don't we r in plaid
pants this is the only guy with the
orange hair so we kind of made you so
the guy with the orange hair we're
stupid madras boxer shorts that's
discriminatory look even the sheep the
sheep just gave me a look
like what's with that
the black sheep keep checking me out and
the other guy that molested me last
night
all right so he finds nothing all right
so follow me over here we're gonna get
some wood all right so you follow me
they put no effort into the graphics
this looks like a world if you have
glaucoma you should be called a total
world the pressure in your eyeball is
too high your vision is so impaired you
put on madras shorts and you don't know
that sheep just keeps eating let's get
out of here get out see
okay let's chop something down but God's
sake okay nothing's happened we've grown
poorer and older oh I know you're okay I
need to get on the ground - I keep
digging into the ground enough you know
I fled Ireland to not do this at
nighttime monsters come out sir monsters
yeah and they kill us so uh monsters
coming out yeah those are scary monsters
my six-year-old can draw a better
monster than that
that's a skillet in the shoots bows and
arrows without saying yeah
all right then we're gonna make a run
for this house real quick go bleh all
right where the hell is a house all
right okay we got in the house anymore
upwards of two guys
[Applause]
my shortest total expect origin is there
a admire say once in college so what
would you rate the C's not gonna be nice
minecraft which I understand is very
popular very popular today pop good so
young people that really can't see well
people have never seen when a real house
looks like and would like depressing
climates I'm still confused I don't know
what we accomplished I don't know why
the monsters were so good with bow and
arrows confused about that I mean
they're monsters that you just rip your
head off what I have bows and arrows I'm
doing out of an 88 and eighty-eight
being pretty good a 110 being excellent
a 150 being awful me being not bad I
give this let's say a 26 see make
yourself minecraft please go to the
nearest lens crafter get fitted for some
eyeglasses
[Applause]
[Music]
that's helpful you can see the other
video games I've reviewed at team
koco.com slash clueless gamer you should
check with me before you make this very
expensive purchase
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]